what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time while
wall street is trying to get rich
the rest of us just trying to get our
launch money right i'm here with polina
as you can tell we're in new york you
know why because it's cold
out here we were too giant it is cold
out here
so i got a sweatshirt on that's why
she's got this nice little jacket on
but don't forget that while it is cold
out here you know it's hot
block fire accounts because they pay an
interest go to blockfi.com
and sign up today blockfy.com
you can earn up to 8.6 apy in that
interest bearing account
or you can sign up for the waitlist for
the credit card it's coming
regular credit card you swipe you get
back bitcoin instead of cash
no-brainer i'm an investor i'm a happy
user and you will be too if you sign up
at blockfit.com
let's get into the news maybe we got
some controversial things to talk about
maybe not i don't know but surprise me
the u.s jobs market recovery accelerated
its pace last week as fewer americans
headed to the unemployment line
first time claims for unemployment
insurance total totaled
547 000 well below the
dow jones estimate for 603 000
in a new low for the covid19 pandemic
era they're saying that they're saying
that it's
becoming closer to where it was
pre-pandemic though there's plenty of
distance to cover
wrong still like a hundred percent
increase
it used to be down in like the hundred
to two hundred thousand people
uh but now half a million just so we're
clear half a million
people last week filed unemployment for
the first half
a million people filed for unemployment
last week
you know why because the only first time
you know why it's first time
because like 50 million people or
whatever the number is
have filed for unemployment over the
last year we literally have run out of
people to file for unemployment
it says still about 8 million fewer
americans are at work
than before covid eight
million americans are not
working that were working last february
that's wild
eight million eight
million people open
up the economies let's go the vaccines
here
let's roll credit suisse
asked investors for up to two billion
dollars in fresh
capital after losses from arcago's
capital management
swelled more than previously disclosed i
think they lost like five
billion dollars yeah it um
adding to a 4.7 billion dollar charge in
the first
quarter it's wild bill wong taking down
credit suisse
yeah so credit suisse lost 5.5 billion
dollars so far from the hedge fund's
failure
so it's raising money i mean it's
raising two point
two two billion one customer
costs them 5.5 billion dollars
and they're worried that people aren't
diversified enough who invest in bitcoin
you know what would have happened if
they put some of their money in bitcoin
they would have made up for that 5.5
billion dollar loss what is this
accent is this southern accent nope
okay i'm just i'm tired of the garbage
in this world
i'm tired of all the nonsense what's
this
accent i'm tired it's not even southern
it's kind of like jamaican a little bit
i don't know listen what i do know is
the following
credit suites had 5.5 billion dollars
white
because of one over leveraged hedge fund
oh wait wrong it's not a hedge fund it
was a family office
so it's gonna be very interesting if all
of a sudden you have
family offices that are acting like
hedge funds in terms of the amount of
capital and the types of investments
they're putting on
should they be regulated like hedge
funds or
should they not big question i
personally
think that they should not be why
because it's not a hedge fund it's
personal capital but what i do think is
that banks maybe should do better
diligence
and make sure that they're not getting
in situations where the family office is
over leveraged and a slight downturn in
the stock price of some assets
could cause massive losses across wall
street
bless your heart yeah all right should i
do my uh
river now sharpen no all right dj steve
aoki
says that what's in okay sorry
dj steve aoki is very bullish on nfts
he believes that digital works of our
their collectibles are the future he
said on cnbc you have to believe that
the next world is going to be digital
everyone's going to own a digital wallet
and everyone's going to flex and show
what they think is valuable to
them in their wallet
they didn't have any purple gatorade
left so i had to get blue just for
everyone so basically
nfts aoki has been way ahead of a lot of
things i
tend to know why one of our mutual
friends
dan fleischman is very very close with
him and he keeps him on the
latest technology trends like sporting
cards which aren't really technology but
more investment trend
and nfts and therefore that is why steve
aoki is going
all in he also is very good friends with
blau
any of you who know who blau is not only
a cea dj but he's also done very well
selling nfts and so i think this is a
natural extension of steve aoki's
uh entire brand can music files be nfts
they can you can actually digitize them
nft
them and get rocking so i can own an
original
song yes and you could actually own the
only version of that song
that's cool next apple reportedly wants
to add more
social features to imessage setting up
yet another fight
with facebook apple was working on
enhancements
what are the enhancements well what are
they gonna say their enhancements maybe
they gonna mess up imessage
i'll be the judge if they're
enhancements or detriments
so i think there's gonna be like private
things yeah
yeah anything anything
bueller bueller bueller
features exactly those privacy changes
take effect likely to spur more
cries a foul play from zuckerberg and
company and apple will eventually pitch
the new social features
in imessage as a private way to share
updates photos and videos
with close friends and families and
beyond that the companies are working on
all this stuff
privacy so essentially apple is going
encryption
no no no no no apple is going to create
the ability
that makes it easier to share photos and
videos and have social conversations
with your friends and family and do it
in a private setting rather than go
one too many in a social i would like
that feed
type experience all right well if you
would like it then maybe you can stop
messaging me garbage
huh jeff are you okay
jeff bezos drake and others invest 80
million
in sports media company over time this
has been very well covered in
joe's newsletter huddle up
uh what do you think this is a
no-brainer
duh why huh even a number of nba players
over time actually
do well read it they're a media company
it distributes original sports content
they also have a basketball league that
they've started that is going to serve
as an alternative for going to college
what yes wait what do you mean
alternative to going so right now the
rules are that if you wanna play in the
nba you gotta go play one year
uh you gotta be one year removed from
high school so most people what they do
is the rule was designed for them to go
to college for one year
but now all these kids are like it only
says i have to be out of school for one
year doesn't mean that i have to go play
in college
so now these leagues are popping up that
are saying look we'll pay some money and
then come work come play here
and then that'll give you exposure and
don't go to college but basically this
is like a
like almost like the minor leagues for
the nba huh
i think it's very smart if you know that
you're gonna go play in the nba why i
gotta get a college degree [ __ ] if he's
not even gonna play in the nba why
getting a college degree
overtime says it has raised more than
140 million
and in march the company made headlines
when it announced over time elite
a basketball league for 16 to 18 year
year olds
that allows them to earn at least 100k a
year hold on a second 16 year olds are
still in high school
yeah you could drop out too
oh i don't know about this okay
all right well your head don't know
about it it is
ask lunch money time i have an update
i have an update i think i told everyone
yesterday that i made contact
with moist i not only have made contact
with moist
i have communicated both audio
visual and uh
video we have made contact we had done a
uh experience we were able to look at
each other
square in the eye digitally i told him i
am the captain now moist
we talked he told me his life story told
me his life goals told me what he's
gonna be doing this summer
we are on the same page we are going to
continue to communicate make contact
with each other
moist soggy wet sorry for soggy and wet
moist got the call when i call you
answer he answered
hopefully we're going to figure out some
stuff to do together i asked him why did
you use the name
moist on youtube he said moist has been
my name on youtube since i was 13.
and i think it's funny and i said i
think it's funny too so we're gonna get
some closure
with moist for everyone who watches
because he will appear
on this show tomorrow literally we
talked about you not telling anybody
that it'd be
a surprise tomorrow we didn't know that
we never talked about that well guess
the surprise is out moist will be on the
show
tomorrow so make sure you tune in
because my wife can't keep a secret but
i didn't know we talked about it
you and i talked about it yes i wasn't
there this is a
live capture there this is a live
capture
of paulina doesn't listen all right it's
ask lunch money time
ask elem in the comments below raymond
hahn has
a comment or a question for me paulina
if you weren't with pomp what percentage
what percentage of your wealth would be
in btc probably more
than if i was with him no no you're
wrong because right now my
my thing is zero but if i didn't know
you i would be like what is this
what is this and i'd put maybe you know
500 a thousand dollars just so i'm
exposed i'm diversified
yeah who am i kidding i'd go buy stuff
without money
i'm kidding no i would i would do it why
do you think i wouldn't do it
i didn't say a single word exactly no i
was trying to zoom in that's
all i was just trying to zoom in
i'm a jeep is back he has a question
he said i have been watching the show
for a couple of weeks love it so far i
have a question for anthony
how would someone that has no background
in finance or programming getting to the
crypto career field
my background is a mechanical engineer
and i currently work as a cae
engineer how to even start trying to
transfer to crypto and find a job what
skills are the employees look
the employers looking for if possible
please give some specific
tips and not vague answers like learn
about
blockchain sorry if that was blunt
i wasn't even that blunt that was like a
whole paragraph beep beep i'm a jeep
you said you're a gaff
there's an r in there
not in english uh yes in english
actually just kidding um so here's what
i think that you should do it's just
like transferring to any new industry
right there's three things that you need
to be able to do one you need to be able
to understand the industry specific
terminology
concepts uh definitions all that stuff
the second thing is that you need to
have a skill set
that directly fits the job that they
want so do you want to go into customer
service make sure you got customer
service skills
you want to go into accounting make sure
you got accounting skills you want to go
into marketing make sure you got
marketing skills right
you have mechanical engineering skills
great if there are mechanical engineers
there are some companies in crypto that
are hiring for mechanical engineers
they're usually doing some sort of
hardware
uh type um you know products so there's
something like a start nine labs or
potentially foundation which does
hardware wallets like there's all kinds
of stuff that you could go and you can
look at mechanical engineering
but if you say hey i actually don't want
to do that or i don't want to work with
those types of companies
then you may have to re-skill yourself
in a new type of skill
the third thing that you have to be able
to do is you have to be able to
articulate both the
industry knowledge and also the skills
that you have in order to position
yourself to the employer to help the
employer understand that if they hire
you
why you will be able to move the company
forward too many times people go into
job interviews
and what they try to explain is listen
you should hire me
because i can do this specific job
but what most employers want to hear is
i'm going to hire you to do this job but
when i hire you for this job
you're also going to be helpful able to
help my entire company move forward
you're going to be forward thinking
you're going to be creative you're going
to be a self-starter you're going to go
into work every day and you're going to
say you know what i've already done my
job my job today took me four hours but
you know what i thought here's a great
idea that could help our business we
should do a b
and c and also i found the two people
inside the company that could
potentially help
accomplish this we've put together a
proposal we'd like to propose that along
with our regular jobs we also have this
new initiative that we're going to
attack
and that will move the company forward
we'll make more money for everyone who
is a shareholder and therefore
i am doing a great job it is one really
run long run on sentence please don't
put it that way but the sentiment is
right
so the whole point is make sure you got
the industry knowledge make sure you got
the skill set that specifically fits the
job
and then be able to articulate to the
employer or to the hiring manager not
only why you can accomplish the job at
which they are presenting as an
opportunity
but also how you specifically if you are
hired by that company can help them move
forward because if you're not moving
forward you're moving backwards if
you're not adapting you're dying and
nobody is around here to die you watch
lunch money you're trying to adapt
you're trying to grow you're trying to
win you're trying to be the king
of whatever you do that was
interesting but i hope that answered
your question beep beep i'm a jeep
that's all for today guys later
miami's better than new york bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block lies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to eight point six
percent interest
on a deposit in an interest bearing
account go do your own research there's
risk associated but eight point six
percent is pretty compelling
so click on the link in the description
say thanks to the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends